[Música]
sandy sour wts más allá a ser una zona
desértica con un particular encanto es
un lugar que ha demostrado estar lleno
de misterios y hoy vamos a explorar uno
de sus más oscuros secretos
si nos dirigimos a este punto que te
estuve enseñando en el mapa
encontraremos lo que parece ser una casa
destruida
en su interior hallaremos una página de
un periódico con un artículo acerca de
un asesino serial apodado el asesino del
infinito
[Música]
su nombre era mero brand murió en 2004
en la penitenciaria bolingbrook según
reportes de la policía y asesinó a ocho
personas pero sus cuerpos jamás fueron
encontrados
no muy lejos de ese lugar podemos
encontrar lo que solía ser la casa del
asesino la cual fue quemada por los
vecinos en esta casa podemos encontrar
indicios y detalles de los crímenes de
guerra hms lo cual nos ayudará a
solucionar este misterio siendo lo más
claro un mensaje escrito en la pared que
dice ahora 8 lo que claramente significa
que desde un principio el brawn tenía
planeado asesinar a 8 personas
pero si nos adentramos más en la casa
podremos ver más pistas como por ejemplo
unos zapatos colgados del techo
probablemente perteneciendo a alguna de
sus víctimas un mensaje escrito en la
parte de atrás de la casa en donde sus
vecinos le advierten al asesino que no
vuelva nunca o lo más llamativo de todo
este otro mensaje escrito en la pared
que dice el número 8 es un infinito
hacia arriba lo que además de
referenciar su gran obsesión por el
número 8 nos revela el origen de su
sobrenombre el asesino del infinito
[Música]
llegados a este punto el mapa podremos
encontrar nuestra siguiente pista ya que
el mismo asesino escribió un mensaje en
una roca en donde mediante un tipo de
rima detalla cada uno de sus asesinatos
lamentablemente la rima se pierde en la
traducción pero esto es lo que dice el
mensaje
el primero está acabado el segundo fue
divertido el tercero trató de correr el
cuarto llamó a su mamá el quinto está
sin vida el sexto ya no es nada el
séptimo está en el cielo el octavo no
tardará
a pesar de que las pistas dejadas por el
asesino eran cada vez más descriptivas
los cuerpos de sus víctimas jamás fueron
encontrados pero air hands antes de
morir dejó un último mensaje en donde
nos daría la última pista sobre este
misterio
[Música]
si vamos al lugar donde el medio air
france vivió sus últimos días la
penitenciería bolingbrook en el patio
central de esta prisión podemos
encontrar escrito en un mural el último
mensaje dejado por el asesino esto es lo
que dice el mensaje donde el agua se
encuentra con la tierra y el fuego era
arrojado ahí los ocho del infinito se
quedarán hasta que yo vuelva
claramente y brahams no podrá volver
pero este mensaje nos da la información
suficiente para descubrir el paradero de
todas sus víctimas pues la primera línea
del mensaje hace referencia a pequeñas
islas que fueron creadas a partir de la
erupción de un volcán bajo el agua
además de eso en la casa de dirhams hay
un dibujo en la pared que también vemos
en este último mensaje siendo este
dibujo en realidad de un mapa en donde
se acudimos y ya habiendo reunido todas
las pistas bajo el agua finalmente
podemos descubrir el lugar donde mero en
brians que el asesino el infinito oculto
los cuerpos de sus víctimas
[Música]